okay so we're to start our tour and
we're you gonna take this first I want
to tell you this it's pitch-black it's
dark in here we're using a light on top
of the camera it really still but it's
just gonna start opening doors and
there's gonna be surprises behind those
doors man I don't want surprise right
I don't want surprises I just want to
okay go ahead just let me show you some
stuff okay all right let's see there's
that that's the old saloon in here I got
dead bodies in here you have what in
here what are you doing man what yeah
why hey no no just one more for real
though for real no one second hello
hello yo I thought after that I heard
like a little kid but I don't know if it
was a door squeaking or not so that's
what you guys do but I'm serious right
there those are two dead bodies those
two dead bodies were years an odd
fellows initiation ceremonies go look at
the wall the top that was found in the
Attic of an old Odd Fellows temple in
New York I mean come on we're all coming
in delivered it was literally like in an
Indiana Jones type crypt and my had to
like what I borrowed out and there was
like black flies that came out of it and
it stunk right here but these are Odd
Fellows skeletons they were used during
these initiations and the new initiate
s-- would have to stare into the face of
mortality to gauge their own death so
why don't you go do that no no I'm good
I'm good no I'll do it
no no I'm good I'm good I let me stare
at it from right here now we got a look
don't look up on right over there and
then you look right into the skull it's
really cool experience and you can see
okay I've done it but do the top one I'm
doing it right now I'm gonna get it
right up Ozzie no no no no I can't get
it so this woody have you walk up on it
yeah you just you go up on it like this
and you stare into the face of the skull
and you face your own mortality and this
is what was done this one here is like
this is a
I get really a strong energy from this
one right here this one was found in the
Attic of an old Odd Fellows temple in
New York and it was delivered and like a
wooden like [ __ ] like you'd see out of
Indiana Jones and I literally had to use
a crowbar and all these black flies came
out but once we put this one in here we
don't we haven't had honestly too much
activity in this particular room but we
did capture this like black mist on one
of our full-spectrum cameras right in
this spot so it's really cool but
everything happens right outside the
door let me show you more stuff whoa
what's that over what is that oh that's
just a deceased puppet heart attack oh I
can't wait to show you more stuff this
is my old haunted art gallery come here
and look at this why why oh this is cool
you're gonna like this I'm gonna like
yeah you're gonna really like this one
cuz I have a challenge for you Kevin
like I needed a challenge yeah you're
gonna have a stick together
stay with me you got a terabytes coming
with me okay so this is one of my more
well known items this is Bela Lugosi's
haunted mirror
okay now Bela Lugosi he was really into
the arena we used to use mirrors for
scrying we all know him from Dracula my
favorite movie this was in his house and
when he died and moved on it stayed in
his house and somebody else moved in by
the name of Frank solitaire this man was
brutally murdered he had mob ties and
that murder is still unsolved so I
believe that when Bela was using this
mirror using it for scrying he left this
mirror as an open portal that mirror
then absorbed all the energy from that
murder and possibly the spirit of the
murder himself so Frank's Electra's
niece Cindy Lee ended up acquiring the
mirror she hung it in her daughter's
bathroom and at that point there was a
dark figure that would literally reach
out of the mirror grab her by the throat
leave marks on
neck and she ended up having to get
mental help for this now that I've had
it hung here there's been some things
that have happened
I had a famous vampire come here and
look at the mirror he doesn't get
intimidated by things like this so he
decided to have fun with it and try to
taunt the spirit his girlfriend was
standing over here he ended up looking
at his girlfriend turned back to the
mirror
went back to his girlfriend started
walking towards her fell hit his head
was literally unconscious and as his
girlfriend was bending down to help him
she had something grabbed her neck and
had marks appear on her neck and it was
all captured on that camera well this
little security camera here so I'm not
gonna force you to do it do you want to
look into their actually do I want to
look into the death mirror do I want to
look into a vampire spirit of javac
terton no no one can't come here and not
look into this Kevin are you gonna look
in the mirror go ahead you look in the
mirror alright I'll do it first
go ahead you look in the mirror first
okay go ahead and and and look into it
it's not don't worry it's not it's not
like something's gonna happen you just
don't know you could have an experience
or nothing could happen go ahead and
just take a quick peek you cannot take a
poll of the room should I do can't come
over here right do you think um all the
way here not look at it alright
look oh wow that mirror is amazing give
it at least five seconds okay here we go
nothing happened nothing happened about
that's what you think no no right now
listen here's the thing okay
well nothing may happen instantly your
mission your investigation of being here
and all this doesn't end when you leave
I want you to pay attention to what
happens tonight when you go home if
there's any odd dreams any odd
nightmares any activity and
room that means that something may have
attached itself to you know them more
fear that you show these objects like
you were just doing the more vulnerable
you will be oh so so what I have to do
is I have to man up and be in here and
be like I'm not afraid of y'all do
whatever you do but I'm just saying if
you show a lot of fear these spirits
these entities will want you even more
because they like that emotion okay
that's how they feed off of I'm not show
any more emotion the whole time movie
like I said no more emotion so what's
cool about this haunted museum is you
never know what you're gonna find oh oh
yeah you're the caboose right now oh
yeah yeah it could be upset okay one of
the topics move me and this is some of
this stuff is automated like that's an
old antique but what I want you to do
right now Kevin I want you to open this
door but norm is breakdown this is one
of the only doors you know you know what
you're gonna find dr. Jack Kevorkian
what's what's in here man come on come
let's go what is there yeah we'll get to
that
oh my god welcome to dr. Jack kevorkians
office okay so right now Kevin you're in
dr. Jack kevorkians office as you know
dr. Jack Kevorkian yeah is a notorious
figure in our history a lot of people
are for it
a lot of people were against it here in
assisted-suicide yeah he was convicted
of a murder he did spend time in prison
but I want you to look at some of these
prints here this is original artwork
from dr. Jack Kevorkian and if you look
at some of this stuff you see these
faces behind here these look like
demonic spirits it kind of really lets
you know what's in the mind of this guy
our monitor just started flipping out
our monitor literally just started going
crazy oh yeah it froze it's doing all
kinds of weird stuff let's hope that's a
sign for a bigger dude
what is that I don't know what that is
not even our camera doesn't that what is
this
when these spirits are triggered by
something - they will manifest and as
they are manifesting they will affect
electronic equipment so that's a good
sign that something could a good sign
well what's in the room something's
really cool for real no this is an
awesome awesome this is one of my best
artifacts that I have go in there oh
it's a van go in go in on touch it no
I'm not touching anything in here touch
it I'm not touching anything in this
building I feel like the haunted oh my
god okay don't work in death van so he
would kill people in the van this is it
oh [ __ ] okay okay that's just a
mannequin okay listen I just saw a body
it's just a mannequin it's just it's all
body in the business the mannequin okay
come on come on come on here come in
here you guys go I'm gonna follow the
camera crew I'll buzz dr. Jack
kevorkians death van now this van this
is a piece of of history this is where
dr. Jack Kevorkian conducted a lot of
assisted suicides and he would do it
through two different means either by
the Thanet Ron or the mursaat Ron the
mursaat Ron used carbon monoxide gas and
that's how a majority of the people
chose to die under the hands of dr. Jack
Kevorkian this is the very first lady
that died in the van Janet Adkins and
what's really cool is is I met dr. Jack
kevorkians attorney that's Geoffrey
Fieger over there and Geoffrey Fieger
originally thought that this van was
destroyed him and Jack took it to a
scrapyard because he knew that people
would want it like this mm-hmm
but they left they didn't I witness it
being
smashed the owner of the scrapyard kept
it and it ended up in my hands you don't
believe me this is the original title
hand signed by Jack Kevorkian himself
amazing artifact let's go no I'm not
touching it listen don't touch it
all that I'm saying is it's a very cool
thing now why would I touch this because
to directly contact yourself with these
items is a really cool thing now a lot
of them I have in cases this is one that
almost like you actually touch you can
connect with the energy of its past here
we pay people
I'm pay respect I pay my respects per
there's more to go kindred we have got
to go to a church after this we go to
church
kindred sad feeling in here but let me
show you something that's on the
opposite side of the spectrum in terms
of energy once again welcome to the
haunted Museum jail now I want to show
you a recent item oh wow this is crazy
where's everybody so look this is
controversial there's a lot of
controversy some people - okay people
dumped John Wayne Gacy yeah originals
these are originals this is original
john gacy artwork the killer clown who
cares so many different boys he was the
description of pure evil now you got to
remember I don't glorify any of these
people I have their stuff on display
because it is cursed that's dark and
here we can learn about these tragic
events in our history
now Kevin when it comes to serial
killers this is one of the most well
known Ted Bundy this guy was horrific
and what he did yeah and his stuff is
very hard to acquire we all know the
Volkswagen bug now this is his disguise
eyeglasses you know he escaped a couple
times when he was in custody after he
escaped the second time he stole another
Volkswagen and at that time
he tried to abduct a fourteen-year-old
named Leslie Parmenter in February 8
1978 in Jacksonville Florida he was
wearing these eyeglasses to disguise
himself not only from the police but
also from the victims this guy had an
addiction to kill and so he was
disguising himself from the victims
because his face was all over the news
everybody was looking for him after he
tried to abduct Leslie Parr mentor the
following day he abducted then murdered
12 year old Kimberly leach so it's
obvious that he was wearing these
glasses during that event as well and
you dropped 50k to get these glasses
stuff isn't cheap 50,000 yeah and again
I put this stuff on display because we
don't want to forget these events in our
past there's a lot of TV a lot of
television a lot of movies about serial
killers and this and that and it's not
an obsession with the serial killers
it's what would make a serial killer do
this when he's so normal-looking you see
him over here in his mug shot right over
here I mean if you look at this guy I
mean he was going to law school he was
wearing a suit you looked at him and
everybody said how nice he was but he
had a mind of evil then the part that
I'm interested in Kevin is what turns
the page for these other they're not
born serial killers something happens to
them in life and I look at the
background in the occult and you know
you look over here the Son of Sam how
much say that again Holland right and
you look over here like the Son of Sam
who is known to be possessed by demons a
lot of these serial killers have a lot
of things in common they all heard
voices they all did devil rituals they
all summoned demons and so from that
part I'd like to research that yeah this
is it's fascinating now in the jail cell
that you've built there does that have
any connection Kay and I notice you also
have serial killer Santa that's Santa
Claus
one that you don't want to sit on his
lap now look these jail bars everything
this is all from a real jail I wanted to
have a familiar environment for where I
believe these objects belong behind bars
we literally cut these out of a jail in
Iowa serial killer Santa this is James
Robinson he's known as the slave master
and he did a lot of bad things you know
he murdered a lot of different women and
this is the outfit that he would wear
that is his outfit yeah that's the
actual outfit that you would wear outfit
are you there's photos of him wearing me
out how do you get something like that
how did you get that it's very hard to
find this stuff I receive a lot of this
from the families directly of the serial
killers oh my god or sometimes there's a
few different people as well that deal
on this kind of stuff that I get it from
oh my god so here's the Mansa stuff but
I don't think we're covering that right
no okay I mean wow yeah Wow Wow
so like these John Wayne Gacy paintings
can you imagine that the hand that
painted these paintings are also the
hands that are responsible for killing
so many different boys and again they're
here they exist so I want to put them in
jail where they belong and that's the
retourner sentence even for the objects
of these killers okay so this is really
where I wanted to take you Kevin yeah
I'm coming I'm just making sure now do
you remember I was telling you in the
beginning about the basement and how in
the 1970s they were doing double rituals
here this leads to the basement when I
bought this place I bought it from the
State Bar of Nevada all the lawyers and
everybody that tests and and tests the
lawyers to become lawyers so when we
were here I had one of the staff come
here and she was standing here she was
in a business dress and I was talking to
her about some of the things that would
happen to stay
and as I was speaking to her she was
telling me that all the staff would put
sea salt along all these doors here
those were their offices and they never
went to the basement if they did they
went on a buddy system and when she was
telling me this something literally came
up these stairs and latched on to her
she began to cry she began to convulse
and as she was walking this way there
was a scratch that appeared on her arm
and so after witnessing that I thought
she was having like a medical event or
something but that really started
showing me that this house this this old
historic mansion this is it this is
supposed to be the right spot for the
Haunted Museum and so down here first of
all I just want what it says do not
enter so normally you do not let people
down nobody's allowed down here except
for me well we're gonna go down here
yeah we're gonna go down we're gonna go
down we're gonna go down so you remember
what I said though that this was used as
a devil worshipping ritual site okay so
let's go down I cover celebrities that's
what I do I go to movie premieres and
stay on a red carpet I don't go down to
where play people used to devil worship
you down there yeah let's go Zach I'm
okay let's go now we may not want
everybody down here how what are you
saying let's go down I would really like
to see if you know it gets really cold
did you get down here oh yeah it gets it
gets the energy gets really strong - oh
look my watch just popped on and said
it's cold what is there my Apple watch
what did it say what did it just say
that out of the blue I don't know it
just popped up it doesn't seem
particularly cold okay it's it's it's
getting it the temperature yo go aw
where's the lights there
there's just some faint lights here
y'all bring this camera like please whoa
what is this chair it's just it's just a
chair okay all right it's just this it's
just a chair you know I'm walking real
slow I'm gonna bring you somebody down
who are you talking to who are you
talking to I just when I come down here
I speak to them I speak you speak to who
the spirits this is where I come down
and I have my alone time and I will say
that I do not participate in any devil
worshipping rituals however this is the
site where it happened and this is what
its gonna stay as so so now what are we
where are we going we're gonna go down
and so though we gotta go further down
yeah we're gonna go the area where all
the rituals took place all right here we
go y'all good
oh man it's getting really dark and
there's a satanic thing on the floor
yeah this is where this is where it all
went down right in here
so obviously this this was painted on
you know we did this what we want to do
is is is show and preserve what happened
down here without actually doing it
obviously so what are the different
things in here
these are Baphomet Baphomet statues some
of the other things are just you know
just just gothic you know Gothic themed
stuff sconces and stuff like that but
it's it's okay are you okay
I mean I feel okay right now that's good
I feel okay what I'm not gonna do okay
what am I would've lost that was not
ever dude what was that I don't know
okay I thought I heard like a bang above
our head but is there somebody here are
you messing with their camera equipment
do you want to mess with one of us
physically can you show yourself like
you have
all right okay yeah yeah yeah just I
feel okay though do you feel I do I do I
feel I feel good you feel good yeah I
don't honestly I don't feel any thing
around me sometimes you'll come down
here by yourself
yeah when you come down here is it dark
there's some times that I'll come down
you're like like to be honest it feels
kind of clear at the moment it doesn't
feel super strong and I don't know when
that's gonna happen there's times where
I come down here where I'm walking and
I'm literally like doing this to the air
to try to move like that's how heavy it
is but when I'm here I believe that this
museum this place this was all set up
before a long time ago I know that
sounds crazy but every single room every
item that I have acquired has just laid
out into this perfect puzzle and when I
come here I can hear the energy if that
makes sense I'm just in tune with it
sometimes mm-hmm but when I'm here I
escape down here and I literally feel
like I can communicate with the spirits
and they're listening and they can do
things that I tell them to do I know
that sounds bizarre to the non-believer
or even believers mm-hmm but to me it's
very real and it's a very real part of
my life and I love being here I'll sit
at home when I'm not filming Ghost
Adventures and I have to come down here
I have to I have to feel this I have to
feel this energy Wow
so and sometimes it's it's it's
turbulent there's a huge storm but
sometimes it's it's calm but it's the
calm before the storm because things do
happen and you'll will not know and I
have an idea let's get out before the
storm what do you think should we get
out before this no we wait for the storm
no my brother you get out before the
storm oh you get out of the snow you
know I'm very sensitive to this kind of
stuff I didn't choose
it's like they chose me to do this and I
happen to do it on a television show
called Ghost Adventures on the Travel
Channel and this is my life
I want to be around it 24/7 just it's
awesome it really is
[Music]